fourth of july is one of the busiest
times for fire departments all across
the valley
they respond to more than a thousand
calls in one night alone from
injuries to fires
today las vegas fire and rescue blowing
up these watermelons showing the damage
that
illegal fireworks can oppose to all of
us
the only legal fireworks in clark county
are labeled
safe insane even those can cause some
injuries and are not allowed in any city
parks firefighters recommend lighting
those fireworks on a flat surface stay
away from all the dry vegetation
and use a shovel to pick up fireworks
when you're done
let them soak in a bucket of water for a
couple hours so they don't set other
stuff on fire
the mayor stopped by to help with this
demonstration
i was having the best time blowing up a
watermelon
and i think what's happened is i've
learned that
wow is that a powerful powerful tool
we just want everybody to be cautious
take care of themselves
their pets everyone but use good sense
now if you are caught with any illegal
fireworks the fine
starts and the key word there is starts
at 250 dollars